right nope no i think that [ __ ] was
produced by trilla that [ __ ] was
awful oh whoa it was so low but i
watched it oh yeah yeah i love that i
gave it a chance
i gave it a chance it's tough because
you got to realize
i know we're gonna make fun of hollywood
being so woke and they try to go so far
left
yep no makeup that's fine but the thing
is
a huge night no makeup that's fine
yeah that's fine that's where the oscars
are at these days we need to bring that
back
we need to bring it back oh judas and
messiah they won you look like the ghost
from the movie far left anyway
so um yeah it's just it's just
the dusk is just like such an old
platform man like trying to figure it
out it's just awkward the whole time the
production was low budget
never heard of 99 of the [ __ ] movie
that's what i'm saying that's all
they should have had little rel hosts
the host the whole thing no real host
yeah no they had them do like this
comedy bit like you give like
celebrities mics and they would ask some
questions about the oscars and no one
knew what the [ __ ] he was talking it was
so awkward but it was funny
uh doing the monologue like no no
he was like what's up i'm a little you
know and it was like you know i'm asked
a few questions like
you know they'd have the dj you know the
famous dj from the roots play you know
oh
like what song is this from did it win
an award anything
it was like so they were like trying too
hard to be like we're hip we like black
people
no we like black people that's love was
the d i was on a drug
yeah oh he's a dj oh he's a dj oh yeah
from the roots
it was just it was just like low budget
i i bet
the lowest ratings i saw it trending but
they said pinocchio i guess pinocchio
had a live
action of pinocchio the whole thing was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] wait it literally looked
like trilla dude
we'll try it talk about it ah
that i just saw it on twitter uh
it was just it was weird damn the only
movie i saw that was
even nominated was sound of metal you
would like that
but he knows how to play the drums you
would love it oh wow
good and what was that uh norman land
what was that
no mad land yeah did you think of that
one no man
because it's clear just trying too hard
man with that asian woman
yeah yeah it was just it was it was
weird and then and these actors think
like
you know like everyone gives a [ __ ]
about their agenda
it's like dude get your reward get the
[ __ ] out
of the speech you're like saving cancer
and [ __ ] it's like dude
you're an actor chill
and they're just saying it should just
it just seems they're doing what they
think oh they people won't relax it
lacks often
nothing's real they're fake their jobs
being fake so
nothing is real nothing's real i don't
think i've ever thought my agents told
them before like hey make sure you
mention it i'm sure the team's like hey
make sure you're talking about they're
like pr channels make sure you talk
about george floyd you know
yeah all right oh it's just it's just
it's just all it's inauthentic
man they're really trying and it was
like low but the thing was a [ __ ] show
and i like the oscars yeah
didn't uh didn't last year's oscars uh
didn't they
all the actors that were in the oscars
do like a uh promo
of them all apologizing or something
yeah for like their white privilege is
great that was last year it was
fantastic
i didn't see that video it was yeah it
was it was like you're on twitter more
than me but you know right that's it
they all got lit up they did yeah
because it was all it was it was like a
black and white video it's great they're
all like wonder woman was on it
i'm sorry bro are you serious bro it was
out of crying
it broke they got lit up so bad for it
like even black people were like please
stop doing this
it was so much like you guilty what'd
you do when i tell you anytime you see a
white person in the airport with a blm
mask on
they did some racist [ __ ] back in the
day
you're not racist you're not that loud
they're always the most guilty
yeah all right right here the top of
2016.
no now you said last year no it's black
and white
oh no there it is i take responsibility
oh that's what it is
oh for the uh naacp oh he was the best
i take responsibility hollywood stars
they got roasted bro he was the worst
one
he was oh my from breaking bad number of
hollywood stars pledging to take
responsibility you know how
oh she's super she's from o.j simpson no
she's from american horror story she's
from a lot she's huge yeah
she's huge okay it was so
brutal it was awesome
they're just so out of touch yeah
they're like
for every unchecked moment for every
time it was easier to ignore than to
call it out for what it was you but i've
seen frozen
justin throw man he's my favorite he's
the north star for fashion
what are you doing every blatant
injustice no matter how big or small
you're right here you're good
she was reading yeah she was every time
i explained you have red hair you're
good
you're just checking out which ones you
have red hair you're good
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets killed in their own homes
these are our brothers and sisters our
friends
our family we are done watching them die
we are no longer we will not
enough is enough i will no longer allow
an unchecked moment
he's reading something oh for sure
they all are stereotypes i'm not gonna
allow your eyebrows
to carry on like this doug they're doing
a self tapes
i will they're doing a selfie
so they bought this but but they thought
this was gonna be like a good thing
dude even though even the far left was
like this ain't it video games
with your nephew should not be a death
sentence shopping in a store
should not be a death sentence
business as usual should not be
life-threatening all right this is too
awkward
yeah i'm done you can hit pause it's
funny it's only two minutes long but it
feels so long
oh it's only two minutes yeah how are we
at now i stand again who's she
[Music]
we can turn the tide it is time
to take responsibility call
out hate the best performance you've
ever had and take action
bro that was the i take responsibility
there you go
there you go what's that schematic
what racist [ __ ] that those actors do
that way they're like dude yeah i'll do
it
yeah because anybody else might i'm not
doing that [ __ ]
they
how many times i've used the n-word
where you feel like you need to do that
that was awkward oh i've never seen that
video i've never watched you you've
never been
oh they got lit
almost career ending for someone chris
and bella lucky she [ __ ]
in frozen oh yeah yeah and she's a
frozen yeah she's the main voice
she's elsa i think oh got it anna
yesterday
i didn't know that i'm sorry kristen
bell oh it's hilarious
some of these actors i haven't seen
since then for real
yeah like that guy who said i had the
best performance he does a lot of voice
over stuff now
he's doing a lot of work he's breaking
bad money he's like yeah he does um
he was just doing bojack horseman for a
while two he did like
on netflix three seasons yeah so the
schedule's obviously
pretty wide open so with the uh you know
breaking bad's over and but they but
they have it on netflix
and he gets paid oh yeah for you're
getting on netflix yeah
get paid i think it depends on their
contract
got it depends on their contract because
they have never i'm pretty sure they do
well but that was dave chappelle's
problem like he got paid for connie
central and the common central sold to
netflix and hbo
and chappelle didn't get paid because
comedy central paid him for his work
for creating that show he signed that
deal that's all right
that's what it is like i wonder if it
depends on contracts yeah
hopefully they are but yeah cause that
was i mean [ __ ] massive show
yeah breaking bad it was huge you guys
all watched it i never watched
i watched one episode was like i'm sad
people love it though but i was like all
right
you know his wife cancer he's selling
drugs getting upset
i don't know what it is i should
probably give it another chance yeah
i it takes me a little bit to get into
like drugs three episodes
drug shows yeah it takes me three
episodes a little bit like the first two
i'm like i don't want to do this my
third one i'm hooked
is it like slow start right all of them
are slow starting
but i've watched uh you [ __ ] seven
times oh yeah don't you
on the road at night when i go in my
room i watch the same series
yeah every night how about that when i
get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son